I want to read one more thing that's
happening in Cali right now and as
chicks I know you guys like to shop
right that's what they say so uh
Westfield here we go Westfield Mall stop
paying it's
558 million dollar mortgage and is
surrendering its namesake San Francisco
Mall the biggest in the city to lenders
in the wake of Nordstrom's planned
closure and plunging foot traffic down
42 percent from 2019 and sales are down
by a third I mean
did you see the video that was going
around even
um earlier this week because all these
stores are closing down in San Francisco
and they're hightailing it out of there
so there was just another video I just
saw it today as a matter of fact of a
bunch more looters taking advantage of
the few stores that remain so they could
empty them out too and and then we got
Gavin on Sean Hannity bragging about the
state
where's Pelosi gonna shop where's she
gonna go oh don't worry she has a
private Shopper she's not she's not
slumming it at the Westfield Mall in San
Francisco but actually one more thing on
the on the emigration that is the exit
of Cali uh this is from ABC 10. census
data shows that just counting domestic
migration in and out of the state
California overall lost 871 000 people
from April 2020 to July 2022 after
accounting for in international
migration the birth and death rate
California lost about 500 000 over two
years now we're about a year off since
that and we know that people have still
consistently been leaving California so